Die P.U., das Podcast-Ufu. Was bisher geschah. Ich erinnere mich nur noch an diese Rosinenbrötchen irgendwie dann auch. Aber ich bin mir auch nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher, ob ich das verwechsel mit Stuck. Ja, unvergessen. Ja, jetzt seid ihr im Bilde. Jetzt sind auch Neueinsteiger endlich mal im Bilde. Wer sich entscheidet mit Folge 343, auch die Gift-Hotline übrigens, 0800 343, wer gesagt hat, das ist der Moment, an dem ich einsteige, der hat jetzt einen kleinen Überblick bekommen. Was man häufig vergisst, ist, dass nicht nur für die Konsumenten ein Was bisher geschah sehr wichtig ist, sondern auch für die Macher. Total. Macherinnen, weil ich für mich ist zum Beispiel auch sehr wichtig, weil ich weiß auch selten, was in den letzten Folgen passiert ist. Ja. Und lustigerweise habe ich dann irgendwann, als wir How to Sale geschrieben haben, habe ich auch mal so ein, da haben Netflix praktischerweise so Staffelrückblicke veröffentlicht, weil man guckt ja nicht nochmal alles selber an und man ist dann irgendwie, man ist dann interessiert, in welchen Sackgasten man sich geschrieben hat. Ich finde es aber auch gut, wenn auch die Figuren so einen Callback bräuchten. Wenn dann so das Handy klingelt, Paul, scheiße Paul. Nur für mich mal ganz kurz, wer genau war Paul nochmal? Ja genau, und Paul ruft an und sagt, hi, ich bin Paul, du weißt schon, der Klasse immer hinter dir sass, der mit dem Problem, der anfängt gerade mit den Drogen zu dealen. Genau, der mich als erstes darauf gebracht hat, jetzt erinnere ich mich, genau, du bist jetzt so ein Blast from the past sozusagen. Exposition. Ja, wir lieben es. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze. Ich bin meines Zeichens Podcaster, Komiker. Und ich wünschte, ich könnte mich noch als Filmemacher im weitesten Sinne bezeichnen. Doch, das geht. Ich glaube, der Zug ist aber abgefahren. Ja, mein Name ist Florentin Will. Ihr kennt mich vielleicht von die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse im Leben von Feed Punch und Last September in Monaco. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Und wer uns heute die Tür aufgemacht hat, als Schlüsselmeisterin quasi, war Corinna. Vielen Dank an Corinna. Die kennt ihr aus. Ja, die Tür auf. Fluch der Karibik, Jurassic Park, The Marvelous Miss Marple und Die Hard. Und die hat die Musik von Die Hard komponiert und
immer die, was bisher geschahs.
Die hat uns die Tür heute aufgehebelt.
Das ist die Nachbarin, die man auch mal fragen kann, die ein Brecheisen
hat. Und Salz. Und Salz, genau, wo man
einfach sagen kann, kannst du mir kurz,
Corinna, kannst du mir kurz die Wohnung
aufhebern? Ich hab schon wieder den Schlüssel
verloren. Und dann kommt Corinna
und erhebt dann auf. Ja, ein Problem.
Das Corinntchen. Ja, wunderbar. Köln. Ach ja, wie geht's dir? Erkenne ich. Den Akzent erkenne ich. Meine Herzstadt. Ja, Corinna hat an vielen mitbewirkt. Eher im Hintergrund, muss man sagen, aber es ist auch wichtig. Aber auch Komparsen. Soundtrack-Macher sind ja immer eher im Hintergrund. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Auch Komparsen brauchst du immer im Hintergrund, müssen immer rumstehen und sie sind trotzdem wichtig. Und da habe ich letztens jetzt von unseren guten Freunden Red Letter Media ein Video gesehen, wo Mike erzählt, dass er mal Komparse war. Also das sind die, die im Hintergrund beim Film stehen, die dann irgendwie von A nach B immer hin und her laufen, und da wurde eine Szene gedreht auf einem Freizeitpark und er hatte die unglückliche Rolle des im Karussell Sitzenden. Das heißt, er musste stundenlang in so einem Kettenkarussell sitzen, weil den Serienproduzenten ist immer noch scheißegal, also da dreht halt einer rum im Hintergrund und man dreht die Szene, dreht die Szene.
Hier ein paar Tipps für den unwahrscheinlichen Fall. Hier sind Florentins und Stephans Tipps.
Top 25 Tipps!
Unwahrscheinlichen Fall, dass ihr mal Kompars oder Komparsen bei einer Serien- oder Filmproduktion seid.
Tipp Nummer eins, ihr werdet irgendwann von wahrscheinlich, ja, in einer Form von zweiter Regieassistenz oder so auf Plätze gewiesen. Je nach Optik und so und was für Kostüme anhabt, werdet ihr irgendwo platziert. Versucht euch bei fahrenden Angelegenheiten, essenden, rauchenden, rummachenden Dingen ein bisschen zurückzunehmen. Versucht der Typ mit dem Ballon in der Hand zu sein. Nein, Arm hoch. Oh, Arm hoch. Die ganze Zeit Arm hoch. Macht etwas, wo ihr sicher sein könnt, dass ihr das fünf Stunden lang durchhaltet, ohne Probleme, ohne Krämpfe und vor allem Tipp zwei, schaut nicht in die Kamera. Niemals. Schaut nicht in die Kamera, macht keine grossen Gesten, nicht zu den Leuten, die sprechen gucken, nicht grosse Augen machen oder sowas. Es sei denn, es ist exklusiv von euch verlangt. In den meisten Fällen, ihr habt das Potenzial, und da wird es auch wiederum lustig, also macht es vielleicht als Prank, ihr habt das Potenzial, diese Zähne zu zerstören. Ihr habt wirklich alles in der Hand. Wenn ihr hinter den Leuten, wenn ihr quasi nicht rauskateriert werden könnt, sondern einfach im Bild seid die ganze Zeit, dann macht's vielleicht. Wenn vor Nacht James Bond und Bond-Girl sich unterhalten, ihr seid verschwommen im Untergrund und rudert so schnell es geht mit den Armen. In gegengesetzte Richtung, rechter Arm nach vorne, linker Arm nach hinten, wenn ihr rudert so schnell es geht. Ja, der macht ein anderes Gedächtnistraining, wo ihr auf den Kopf hauen müsst und den Bauch reiben müsst im Uhrzeigersinn. Mit der rechten Hand drehen, die linke Hand hoch und runter. Okay, wohin will ich vor allem in so Gedächtnistrainings bringen, was ich jetzt nicht ganz verstehe, diesen Zusammenhang. Du nach Stunden da und du kriegst die ganze Zeit irgendwie das Benzin von den Explosionen ins Gesicht, irgendwann brauchst du auch mal eine gewisse Ablenkung. Boah, gestern habe ich, ich habe jetzt ein neues Hobby angefangen, malen mit Ölfarben und da braucht man ja Terpentin, also ich glaube, es ist kein Terpentin oder Terpentin, Ersatz inzwischen. Also, sorry, also Rest in Peace, Eishockey, also das war's, Eishockey ist begraben, wir machen eine Eisbestattung für Eishockey, Eishockey ist fertig. Man kann das wunderbar nebenbei. Und jetzt kommt der nächste Schritt, wir haben einen Aufstieg und zwar zum Malen mit Ölfarben.
Wie viele Ölfarben hast du dir auf Anhieb gekauft?
Nee, mich habe ich zu Weihnachten geschenkt bekommen.
Hast du ein Bild von dir dabei?
Nein.
So was abfordert.
Nein, ich habe noch nicht, ja, abfordert wird ja, aber das ist.
Kann ich das mal sehen?
Nein, nein, es sind noch, die ersten Versuche sind noch sehr schlecht.
Kann ich das, Stefan?
Ist noch ultra schlecht.
Das weiss ich doch, aber trotzdem würde ich es gerne sehen und natürlich unsere Zuhörerinnen
und Zuhörer auch gerne. Wir wollen doch an deinen Phasen teilnehmen. Nee erwarten doch nicht viel. Das siehst du jetzt, ich zeige es dir jetzt, weil es einfach nur sehr schlecht ist und ich wollte erst mal wissen, wie diese Farben überhaupt funktionieren. Sorry, ich muss mich kurz mental darauf vorbereiten. Nicht zu lachen, du unterstützt die Hobbys deines Podcaster-Kollegen, du bist der unterstützende Freund. Okay. Es ist ein generisches Drecksbild. Los geht's. Guck. Okay. Na, ist doch schön. Ja. Ist doch schön für den Anfang. Ja, genau. Also, ich nenne es der Mond. Das ist ein Test, das ist eine Studie. Ach so. Es ist prima eine Farbstudie. Ah, okay. Also von zwei Farben. Es sind zwei Farben benutzt. Da habe ich zum ersten Mal versucht, wie man überhaupt diese Ölfarben mischt. Ja. Keine Ahnung, wie funktioniert. Da muss man auch teilweise Öl hinzumischen, je nachdem wie dick man die haben will. Ich habe noch keine Ahnung. Ich habe mir YouTube-Videos angeguckt, wie Ölfarben funktionieren, habe ein bisschen gemalt. So, ich habe zu viel Terpentine eingeatmet, das ist alles, was ich sagen will. Ich habe gestern so krass Kopfschmerzen gehabt, ich konnte fast nicht einschlafen, weil ich gestern gemalt habe und hatte dann Terpentine. Du bist jetzt Künstler, Stefan, du brauchst jetzt keinen Schlaf.
Aber ich verstehe, warum die alle so dazed. Ja, sich irgendwann ins Ohr abgeschnitten haben, wenn du wochenlang nicht schläfst. Ja, weird werden einfach in den Ateliers, also ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, eigentümlich werden. Also ich kann mir das genau vorstellen, weil ich glaube, es ist das Terpentine, was dann irgendwann das Hirn wegfrisst. Also du behauptest gerade, das gesamte künstlerische Genie unserer Zeit beruht einzig und allein auf Terpentindämpfen. Dass Van Gogh einfach sich getraut hat, mehr einzuatmen. Van Gogh. Van Gogh einfach gesagt hat, ich atme mehr ein als mein elender Erzfeind Van Gogh. Den male ich weg einfach. Der wird weggemalt. der wird weggemalt. Ja, ich glaube, eine andere Zeit. Aber ja, also, nee, keine Ahnung, ich habe ihn noch nicht genau abschließend bewertet. Ich weiß nicht, je mehr, vielleicht werden meine Bilder besser, je mehr Terpentin ich einatme oder je mehr Bilder ich mache. Oder es führt eher dazu, dass man als Gesellschaft, als Menschheit gar keine guten Bilder malen kann, weil wir andauernd mit Terpentin gemalt haben und uns das unser Hirn wegfrisst. Ach so, ich dachte sozusagen, dass der Mensch selbst gar nicht kreativ ist, sondern nur verschiedene Substanzen, verschiedene Arten von Kreativität erzeugen. Ich wollte bei diesem Bitte in die andere Richtung gehen, wo ich war eher der Meinung, dass das kontraproduktiv ist. Aber die Dinge, die wir brauchen zu malen, werden verhindern, dass wir gut malen. Nee, ich dachte, du meinst, dass jede Art von Kreativität so eine Art, also zum Beispiel, wenn du mit Autor bist und mit Tinte schreibst, dann atmest du das ein und dadurch kannst du besser schreiben. Nee, ich hätte es genau andersrum gemeint. Ich dachte aber, dass du es anders meinst. Was ich aber ursprünglich meinte, ist, dass man gar nicht kreativ tätig werden kann, weil Terpentin in der Nase dazu führt, dass man keine Luft mehr bekommt
und die Lunge wegätzt und das Gehirn schmilzt.
Also du sagst, jeder könnte kreativ sein, wenn er die richtigen Substanzen einatmet.
Nein, ganz im Gegenteil, wenn uns die Materialien, die wir benutzen,
nicht davon abhalten, die Tätigkeit auszuführen.
Ich dachte, du hättest was Interessanteres gesagt.
Aber gut.
Ja, so geht es mir bei allem, auf jeder Party, immer. Ah, worüber redet ihr? Ach so, nee, ich dachte, ihr redet über was Spannendes. Nicht über diese gleiche Kotzgeschichte von Larissa von der elften Klasse, über die wir jedes Mal reden, wenn wir mal wieder in dieser Gruppe zusammenkommen. Verstehst du das? Ja, ja, das steht total. Immer, immer werden die gleichen Geschichten ausgepackt. Du bist Vampirplaner? Nein, Terminplaner. Nein, nein. Ach so. Ich bin Bauzeichner, ich bin technischer Bauzeichner. Ach so. Aber dann bist du, dann hau mal ab. Dann hau mal enttäuscht ab. Sei mal so exzentrisch, dass du dann sagst, noch. Und dann schmeißt du deinen Schal um und gehst weg. Machst du ja nicht, du bist dann in diesem Gespräch gefangen. Du bist Managerin eines Vampirs?
Nein, nein.
Nee, ich bin langweiligere, ich habe gesagt, ich bin langweilige Controllerin.
Ach so, ach okay.
Das habe ich gerade gesagt.
Aber, Köttinger, die stelle ich mir auch ganz gut vor.
Ja, guten Tag, ich rufe an für den Herrn Dracula.
Und zwar ist es folgendermassen, er würde gerne bei Ihnen in ihrem Fastfood-Etablissement speisen, und die Sache ist die, mein Mandant hat folgende Situation, und zwar müsste er eingeladen werden in die Filiale. Wir sind fucking KFC. Genau, genau, genau, und deswegen. Sie sind ja beim KFC am Rudolfplatz in Köln gelandet. Richtig, richtig. Und man nannt nur, dass sie es wissen, er wird sich zu erkennen geben und sie müssten ihn dann in die Filiale einladen. Sorry, ganz kurz. Alter, du kannst nicht in die Küche für ihn gehen, du musst auf den Klo machen. Nee, ohnehin brauchst du mich nicht so angucken. Ich hab das letzte Woche gesagt. Ich hab das letzte Woche gesagt. Das ist die letzte Verwarnung, Dino. Sorry. Kein Problem, überhaupt kein Punkt. Wir haben Zeit, mein Kunde hat Zeit. Also wer will, Sie wollen eingeladen werden? Nein, genau. Also mein Kunde wird... Der wird heute gegen 18 Uhr vor der Tür stehen und Sie müssten ihn dann durch die elektronische Schiebetür einladen. Keine elektronische Schiebetür, wir sind der KFC im Rudolfplatz. Sie können froh sein, wenn unsere Tür funktioniert überhaupt. Ach so. Sie müssen drücken oder schieben, es ist nicht so schwer, es steht einfach drauf. Okay. Ich verstehe nicht, ist der alt oder sowas? KFC ist nichts für Sie. Er ist mehrere Jahrhunderte alt, das ist korrekt. Er würde sich zu ergeben, kennen geben, indem der Himmel geschwärzt wird, ein riesiger Vollmond erscheint. Du musst vier Buckets fertig machen.
Ich verstehe das, aber ganz viele Fledermäuse würden erscheinen.
Man kann bei uns nicht reservieren.
Nein, nein, wir wollen gar nicht reservieren.
Ist denn die Familie Hübner noch bei Ihnen da?
Sind die Hübners?
Können wir alle Fresse halten?
Ist die Familie Hübner?
Nee, ich glaube nicht, sorry. Ach so, okay, weil ich dachte, die kämen um 18 Uhr. Kann sein, dass sie um 18 Uhr kommen. Okay, gut, weil mein Mandant hat großes Interesse an der Familie Hübner. Okay, alles klar, er kann einfach reinkommen ins KFC. Ciao! KFC. Fuck it, fuck everything. Uns ist alles egal. Uns ist alles scheißegal. Bring Dracula mit, bring Hulk mit, we don't give a fuck. Aber du kriegst Erfrischungstüchchen, um dir dann das Hühnerblut vor den Händen zu wischen. Ja genau, du kriegst Erfrischungstüchchen und freust dich darüber, die du gar nicht bräuchtest, wenn du gar nicht erst den Fehler begangen hast, um hinzukommen. Entschuldigung, haben Sie auch Erfrischungstücher, mit denen ich mein Gewissen wieder sauber wischen kann? Ja diese ganzen armen Tiere zu Tode gequält werden und für mich sterben? Okay, haben Sie Angst, weil Sie die Tiere konkret umbringen oder weil Sie an der Klimaerwenden masslich beteiligt sind? Achso, nee, dass Sie zu Tode gefolgt werden. Das hätte ich gern. Dankeschön, wunderbar. Oh, Zitrone. Ja, na klar. Und hier haben wir noch eins gegen Flugscham. Ah, wunderbar. KFC, fuck everything. Aber wir haben Kartoffelbrei auf dem Menü. KFC, this one night of the year, wo man schwach wird und denkt so. Ja, wo man wirklich denkt, rock bottom. Rock bottom, heute KFC. Welcome to rock bottom. Das ist ein ... Ja, das wäre mal ein guter Titel. KFC, welcome to your rock bottom. Ich erinnere mich an, eine meiner allerersten Podcast-Ufo-Anekdoten war, wie ich ich glaube, es war Kartoffelbrei gegessen habe, bei KFC als Beilage Kartoffelbrei genommen habe, aber man vergessen hatte, mir den Löffel reinzulegen, weswegen ich ein Stück Huhn benutzt habe, um mir Kartoffelbrei in meine schmatzende, schwitzende Stopfluke hinein zu befördern. Es ist gleichzeitig der einzige Laden, wo das passiert, wie auch der einzige Laden, wo das komplett socially accepted ist, dass du einfach mit der Fleischbeilage, die du in rauen Mengen bekommst, deinen Kartoffelbrei reinschaufelst. Ach ja, herrlich. Gotta love it. Das ist grossartig. Du sollst nicht, I'm loving it oder so, das wäre eigentlich perfekt. Das wäre richtig gut. Das wäre eigentlich sehr gut. Ach, herrlich. Ich habe fertig geschaut, Andor. Die neue Star-Wars-Serie Andor. Sorry, du bist so schnell. Vor zwei Wochen hast du noch gesagt, Star-Wars-Episode 9 hat dich so enttäuscht, du bist kein Star-W mehr, du warst nicht auf der Star Wars Celebration in Oklahoma und jetzt sagst du, du hast dir doch nochmal Andor reingesaugt. Gib mir mal einen kurzen Rewind, geh nochmal zurück und führ mich durch. Was bisher geschah bei Stefan. Wars 9 war so schlecht, dass ich dachte, ah okay, it's done, it's done. Dann kam Mandalorian und so, faul, fand ich faul, fand ich nicht schön. Wie faul, weil der seinen Helm nicht abgenommen hat oder was, weil der gesagt hat, nee, du, sorry, mit dem Make-up und so, könnt ihr mir nicht die Helme aussetzen. Es war offensichtlich nicht Pedro Pascal. Habe ich nicht gesehen, also dem ist behauptet, er war bei der Premiere, aber I don't know. Ich fand das eine sehr, eigentlich eine sehr schlechte, faule Serie. Im Sinne vom Storywriter fand ich sie sehr faul, auch schauspielerisch und im Gesicht. Aber kannst du das nicht als Autor nicht nachvollziehen, dass man mal einen müden Tag hat? Das war eine müde Serie, dass man einfach nicht so richtig in die Pötte kommt. Dass man einfach eher so, oh nee, so ein bisschen einfach auf der Couch, narrativ auch auf der Couch liegt. Das ist so generisch, generisch. Aber halt im Star-Wars-Gewand erzählt und das hat natürlich uns alle da reingelullt und deswegen haben wir das alle geguckt und so. Aber eigentlich ist das doch eine scheiß Serie, da machen wir uns nichts vor. So, nichts vor. Obivine noch eine grössere Katastrophe, Boba Fett auch eine noch grössere Katastrophe. So viel Schrott, nur Schrott. Dann habe ich einfach keine Lust mehr gehabt auf Andor. Dann haben aber alle gesagt, meine YouTube-Starting-Page hat dann schon auch so ... Hat dich quasi gezwungen und vorgehalten, warum es eine Writing Writing Masterpiece ist. Wow, and or ... Not as lazy as all the others. Not as lazy, it's nearly perfect. Und dann ganz viele Leute, die ich auch mag, und auf deren Urteil ich traue, haben mir gesagt, schau, das ist perfekt. Dankeschön, das ist nett. Ich erinnere mich nicht daran, dass du mir gesagt hast. Doch, ich hab ... ach so. Ich dachte, du meinst ... sorry, ich dachte, du meinst. Nee, ist konkret nicht gemeint, aber ... Ach so, weil ich dachte, ich hättest ... Du hast nämlich eine Serie mehr empfohlen, möchte ich jetzt nicht public schämen, aber du hast mir eine Serie empfohlen, wo du dir alles verspielt hast. Du hast dir jegliche Empfehlungen verspielt für die nächsten fünf Jahre. Ich hab die Serie richtig hoch gelobt, und du fandest sie ganz schrecklich, ganz furchtbar, wo ich aber immer noch sag, dass du falsch liegst. Aber wie gesagt, müssen wir ... Es haben viele gemocht, also wahrscheinlich liege ich falsch. Es sei denn, es liegt nicht daran, was der Masse gefällt, sondern was ... Vielleicht hast du auch die falsche Version geschaut. Vielleicht hast du die falsche ... Ich war neidisch, weil ich so was nicht kann. Kann natürlich auch sein. Und deswegen ... Also, es kann viel mitrollen. Ich fand es ganz schrecklich. Deswegen hast du dein Empfehlungs ... Ja. Will immer. Privileg verspielt. Das ist fair. Und ich muss sagen, Andor ist unglaublich fantastisch, ganz toll geschrieben, tolle Dialoge von den Gilroy's, von denen wir beide ja auch große Fans sind wegen Nightcrawler. Dan Gangaroo hat Nightcrawler gemacht, und die sind auch massgeblich beteiligt gewesen, also Showrunner der neuen Star-Wars-Serie, Andor. Kann ich nur empfehlen. Und die war nicht faul, die war eher motiviert, fit. Geile Dialoge, viel Arbeit reingesteckt, einfach viele Details. Und vor allem das Star-Wars-Universum mal wieder genutzt, in allen Facetten. Das ist so schön, dich wieder so aufblühen zu sehen in deiner Star-Wars-Liebe. Jetzt ergeben die ganzen Tattoos wieder Sinn, Mon Calamari,
irgendwie, was halt niemand versteht. Die ganze Zeit Snacke.
Die Snacke die ganze Zeit Mon Calamari.
Und deswegen freut es mich,
dass du wieder zurückgekehrt bist.
Du bist wieder auf der richtigen Seite.
Nein, das werden wir nicht auf der hellen Seite gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, wird man sehen.
Kleine Empfehlung an der Stelle, die du ignorieren wirst,
aber vielleicht für Leute, die auch mal Star Wars von der anderen Seite
erleben werden. Es gibt die
legendäre, unveröffentlichte Comedy-Serie von Star Wars. Eine unveröffentlichte Serie, aufbauend auf Robot Chicken hat George Lucas gesagt, ich habe richtig Bock, eine Comedy-Serie zu machen, hat auch mitgearbeitet, da wurden richtig viele Folgen davon gemacht. Was George Lucas anfasst, wird eh zu Gold. Absolut, dann kam der Verkauf an Disney, damit war das ganze Projekt begraben, weil das nicht gut in die Veröffentlichungsstrategie gepasst hat. Nur Scheiße zu produzieren. Ja, so eine grottenschlechte Serie passt jetzt irgendwie gerade, also vielleicht im Sommer, vielleicht im Sommer, aber gerade haben wir so eine wirklich erbärmlich, unfassbar faule Serie. Ah, okay. Nee, weil wir wollten eine gute machen. Aber ich verstehe nicht, wenn es grad nicht zu euch passt oder so. Okay, nee, bei uns hat man gesagt, ihr braucht grad eine richtig schlechte Serie. Ah, okay. Und deswegen haben wir extra gesagt, macht die richtig unlustig. Ach, aber wir wollten eine richtig lustige, coole Comedy machen. Da haben wir auseinander vorbei. Da gab es ein Missverständnis. Okay, alles klar. Kein Problem.
Gut, aber gut, dass wir das geklärt haben.
Sorry, ja. Dann ruft uns an,
wenn ihr eine schlechte Serie braucht. Wir haben alles
da. Gut, meldet euch. Alles klar.
Und bis heute ist das nicht geschehen. Bis heute
wurde die nicht veröffentlicht, aber man kann
manche Folgen illegal angucken und manche
Bruchstücke, Fragmente
dieser geheimen, mysteriösen Serie sind
auf YouTube veröffentlicht. Star Wars Detours. Es ist animiert und es ist lustig und ich find's richtig lustig. Ja? Ich find's lustig. Ja, find's lustig, weil du es lustig findest oder find's lustig lustig? Naja, es ist halt so der Humor, den Star Wars Fans haben, so, ah, was wäre wenn und so, man interpretiert die Figuren neu und ist es nicht komisch, wenn Darth Vader immer einen Helm anhat Und halt so diese Art von Gag, aber wirklich lustig und immer so zwei Schritte weiter so ein bisschen.
Ich fand es richtig cool.
Ja, cool.
Und deswegen ist es aber auch sehr faul, die Serie, muss man sagen.
Aber vielleicht mag ich auch einfach faule Serien.
Vielleicht mag ich das auch einfach ganz gern, weil ich selber auch manchmal ein bisschen träge bin.
Was ich damit meine, ist, es ist so viel Arbeit reingeflossen, offensichtlich in die Liebe zu den Details und die Dialoge. Und es ist eine komplett toll handwerklich gemachte Serie, die einen Befriedigung zurücklässt. Man hat was mitgenommen und die bereichert das Universum und einen beim Gucken. Und das hat mir währenddessen wahnsinnig Spaß gemacht bei Andor. Auch clever, coole Diskurse so geführt innerhalb der Serie und mal wieder geile Orte gezeigt, auch mal geile Planeten, die er gezeigt hat, coole Kreaturen und so, einfach aus dem Vollen geschöpft. Und das hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Einziger Trickpunkt, den ich habe, ist, wahnsinnig viele Figuren da tragen Daunenjacken. Und zwar diese ganz normalen Daunenjackenen, die gerade modern sind. Alle tragen noch diese puffy North Face-Jacken. So eine Sci-Fi-Serie ist aber auch schwierig, weil konstant kommen und gehen modische Trends und du musst irgendwie treffen, dass du sagst, es sieht nicht albern futuristisch aus. Sorry, Barbara vom Kostüm-Department. Sci-Fi ist halt auch schwierig. Sorry. Nein, dann zieh den Mantel an, einen Cape oder sowas, aber eine Daunenjacke, eine North Face Daunenjacke. Die Hälfte der Figuren haben schon Capes und Jiedis haben alle Capes. Jetzt kann nicht jeder in dem Cape rumlaufen. Und ich verstehe auch genau, woher das kommt, nämlich warum Regisseure, die ich auch schätze und ich fand die Arbeit auch gut. Jetzt kommt die Down-Verschwörung. Meine These ist,
dass dann alle sagen, ja, aber
Harrison Ford hatte bei
Episode 5 auch
diese sehr normale Jacke an.
Mit diesem Fell. Die Jeansjacke.
Auf Hoth. Nee, worse.
So eine ganz normale
Dad-Jacke. Stimmt, ja.
Aber nur im Schnee.
Im Schnee tragen alle wieder ganz normale, tragen alle wieder Jack Wolfskin.s-Gene. Ja, und eine Schiebricht, also super pragmatische Sachen. Und so eine Bommelmütze mit so Katzenohren drauf. Einfach so, da ist dann alles wieder normal von Kick einfach. Sobald es kalt will in einem Fantasy-Universum, haben alle einfach ganz normale Skianzüge an. Hier, Han Solo hatte einfach eine ganz normale Jacke an. Googelt das mal Han Solo auf Hoffnung, trägt einfach eine ganz normale Winterjacke mit so einem Fellkragen. Also wirklich diese typische Lehrer-Vater-Jacke. Ja. So, und ich glaube, wenn das Kostümdepartement dann mal, ja, wollten mal Donnerstag schon freimachen oder mal so ein langes Wochenende oder sowas, dann haben sie halt, ja komm, die Down-Jacke passt schon, dann werden die immer gesagt haben, ja, aber Han Solo auf Hoth.
Ich glaube, das war immer der Go-To-Punkt, ja, aber es ist ja kanonisch, dass im Star Wars Universum gibt es einfach Basic-Ass-Jacken, bitteschön, hier ist unsere, hier ist diese North Face-Daunenjacke, wir haben das North Face ausradiert. Naja, ich meine, es ist ja so bei Filmen, also das kennst du ja bestimmt am besten.
Filme, die Grundprämisse von Filmen ist ja Fehler durchziehen, weil wenn am ersten Drehtag der Schauspieler die falsche Jacke anhatte, kannst du nicht sagen, wir drehen jetzt alles nochmal neu, angedreht, berührt, berührt, berührt, und du musst sagen, ab jetzt, sorry, Entschuldigung, ich hatte leider die falsche Jacke an, ich habe nach dem Mittagessen nicht mehr die Kostümjacke angezogen, sondern hatte meine private Jacke an. Ich hatte noch so einen Cheo-Chip im Mund. Das heißt, Geo-Chips sind jetzt kanonisch. Ja, ist jetzt kanonisch, ab jetzt musst du in jeder Szene immer diese Jacke tragen, weil man sonst fragt, warum hat der nur ganz am Anfang kurz diese Jacke an, diese H&M-Jacke und danach nicht mehr. Das heißt, berührt geführt, du musst es am Ende durchziehen und so funktioniert es. So sind manche Frisuren entstanden, Prinzessin Leia. Auch einfach nur irgendwie aus Scheiss mal so gemacht, um so ein paar Ideen zu probieren. Sie hat Lockenweckler noch dringelassen. Ah, verdammt. Nee, Kopfschmuck. Das ist ein Nabu-Kopf. Ja, das ist alles Kopfschmuck. Aber schau mal, diese, google das will ich mal, Han Solo auf Hoff und oben die ganz normale Skibrille, die er anhat. Es fehlt so welches Uwex-Logo noch so rechts da dran, ich find's fantastisch. Es hat mich ein bisschen rausgezogen, jetzt beim Gucken, weil das jetzt Jacken sind, die auch jetzt gerade alle anhaben. Ja, das stimmt. Und das zieht einen so ein bisschen raus manchmal, wenn die auch dann genauso gefüttert sind. Und ich hab mal ein Interview gelesen, ein spannendes von einer Kostümdesignerin, die gesagt hat, von Star Wars, in dem Universum gibt's keine Knöpfe. Einfache Regel für Sci-Fi, mach keine Knöpfe, weil Knöpfe erkennt man immer als was sehr Menschliches, irdisches. Das stimmt, ja. Weil es ist, auch wenn man da, glaube ich, gar nicht so bewusst darüber nachdenkt, weil wenn du Knopf irgendwo siehst auf der Kinoleinwand, du siehst es immer auf die Erde, weil es muss ja all das geben, es muss ja die gleiche Technologie quasi geben. Wohingegen im Mittelalter gibt es wahnsinnig viele Knöpfe. Also Kostümdesign jetzt mal für Anfänger, je mehr in die Vergangenheit, desto mehr Knöpfe, je mehr in die Zukunft, desto weniger. Man könnte so einen Graphen erstellen, Anzahl der Knöpfe und Zeit und man weiß immer genau, an welchem Punkt sind wir, Kostümbildner reden auch nicht in Jahreszeiten, sondern du redest in ein Knopf, zwei Knopf, drei Knopf, in Knöpfen.
Und du weisst einfach genau, so und so viele Knöpfe haben wir, weil Mittelalter wahnsinnig viele Knöpfe.
Ah, okay. Ja, in Zukunft dann wahnsinnig wenig Knöpfe, also einfach ein abfallender linearer Grab.
Das heißt, wir leben gerade im absoluten Sweet Spot, wo es Knöpfe gibt, ja.
Die Hochzeit für Knöpfe.
Also jetzt haben wir genau den Zwischenschnitt zwischen zu viel und zu wenig. Wir leben eigentlich im Jahr des Knopfes, immer.
Die älteren Semester sagen, es gibt zu wenig Knöpfe, früher war es besser.
Das stimmt.
Aber wir finden ja...
Die Jungen sagen, es gibt zu viele Knöpfe, es ist ein ewiges Hin und Her.
Ja, genau. Sie hat gesagt, keine Knöpfe, stattdessen lieber irgendwie Dinge übereinander, wie
ein Mantel oder sowas und dann so einen grossen Gürtel, da ist ja auch immer ein Blaster
dann oft drin, also irgendwie sowas.
Aber ich verstehe schon, dass sich das irgendwann erschöpft.
Man hat keine Möglichkeiten, mehr Jacken zu schliessen.
Und da habe ich jetzt einfach aber, als ich diese Daunenjacke mit einem normalen Reisverschluss
gesehen habe, habe ich gedacht, jetzt wird es mir so ähnlich zu uns. Auf Coruscant läuft da jemand mit einer blauen Daunenjacke rum, die so puffy ist und so und dann einfach einen Reisverschluss. Und dann ist die Kapuze, es gibt eine Kapuze, und die ist genauso ausgestoffiert wie halt alle anderen Kapuzen von Jack-Wolfskin-Jakken. Ja, aber es gibt vielleicht manche Erfindungen, die einfach so perfekt sind, dass die in der Zukunft nicht mehr verändert werden. Also dass du in der Zukunft einfach noch stinknormale Reisverschlüsse hast, wo alle dachten, wir haben jetzt hier so Laserverschlüsse oder irgendwie so zwei verschiedene Säuren, die sich so zusammenätzen irgendwie so und die man da wieder lösen kann, wenn man dann irgendwie da so drauf tippt oder was auch immer. Ich habe jetzt einfach ein paar willkürliche Ideen gerade, aber da könnte man
irgendwas machen. Aber nein, vielleicht
sind wir einfach am Ende. Es gibt manche Sachen,
da sind wir einfach schon am Ende.
Ja genau, da gab es eine Figur, macht dann
irgendwann
eine Tasche auf,
die sie bekommt, wo etwas drin ist, was sie
benötigt. Und das ist einfach
dieser ganz normale Verschluss,
wo man dort oben und unten diese beiden Dinger reindrücken muss, weißt du, und dann zieht man das raus. Wie nennt man das Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr und links was rein und dann kann man es rausziehen aus Plastik. Und das gab es auch. Ich als Regisseur hätte das in dem Moment nicht durchgewunken. Ich hätte gesagt, nein, wir brauchen einen anderen Verschluss. Es ist so schwer, weil Star Wars spielt ja eigentlich in der Vergangenheit. Long, long time ago. Also irgendwann in der Antike hat man den Reissverschlüssel wieder vergessen und ihn dann in den 60ern wieder ... Aber Long Time A Go spricht für sehr viele Knöpfe. Es stimmt, eigentlich ist es schwierig. Es ist wirklich schwierig. Ich finde Knöpfe auch besser als Reissverschlüsse. Vielleicht habe ich mich auch vertan beim Erzählen dieser Geschichte. Ich glaube nicht, kann man noch mal nachlesen. Also, findest du es cool, so ein Hemd aufzuknöpfen? Findest du es sexy? Also fühlst du dich da so richtig ... Also wenn du so in einer erotischen Situation bist und du hast so ein Hemd und das so aufzuknöpfen, findest du es eher sexy oder findest du es nervig? Nervig. Es ist zu viel. Ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich weiss, dass das im Beisein eines anderen noch ausgezogen werden muss, was ich anhabe, vielleicht in einer Sexy-Sexy-Times-Situation, bin ich darauf bedacht, Dinge anzuziehen, die möglichst unkompliziert auszuziehen sind. Okay, also auch hier können wir einen Graphen aufbauen. Wahrscheinlichkeit auf Sex korreliert mit Anzahl Knöpfen. Je geringer die Wahrscheinlichkeit, desto höher die Anzahl der Knöpfe und je höher die Wahrscheinlichkeit, desto weniger Knöpfe. Also da gehst du dann eher auf Klett. Ich war jetzt auch eher beim Schuh. In welche Richtung geht es dann? Ja, Klett. Also wenn ihr mich draußen seht, abends und feiern, und ich habe ein T-Shirt an und Klett und so große Schuhe mit eins und Kletting, wisst ihr, he's fucking horny, he's on. Der ist vielleicht noch 20 Minuten hier, aber länger nicht. Der ist gleich zu Hause und nicht alleine. Okay. Nee, aber bei mir neulich kam es eine Situation, ich hatte meine Converse an. Diese hohen Schnür-Converse-Stiefeletten, also kennst du die Converse-Struhe, diese Chucks? Ja, ja. Hoch zu schnüren und High Top. High Top, ja, bis ich die ausgezogen habe. Also erst mal ist mein Kopf hochrot, weil ich die ganze Zeit in so einer über dem nach unten hängenden Position bin. Kann auch nicht gut auf einem Bein stehen. Aber es gibt nichts Erbärmlicheres, als wenn man auf einem Bein stehen und dann umfällt oder nach Hals suchen muss. Das geht nicht, das kannst du nicht machen. Deswegen schön gegen die Wand lehnen, direkt von Anfang an. Das ist auf jeden Fall gegen die Wand lehnen ist eh immer sexy. Aber nicht mittendrin, dass es direkt erkennbar ist als last resort. Jedenfalls habe ich diese Schuhe, ja, die habe ich dann als Hindernis irgendwann wahrgenommen, weil man die nicht, man kann die nicht einfach aussehen. Das ist nicht sexy, sexy times. Naja, es gibt ja den guten alten Schuhknecht. Das ist so ein Holz Gestell, wie so eine Sprungschanze, wo du dich mit einem Fuss draufstellst, mit dem anderen hakst du hinten eine Ferse ein und dann, hallo Ladies, dann ist das in kürzester Zeit erledigt, dieses Lied. Wie ich mir deine Wohnung jetzt vorstelle, wenn du Damenbesuch hast, stell dir vor, du gehst an so einen Flur, wo so ganz viele so altbayerische Holz aus so einer schönen Eiche geschnitzt, so hölzerne Mechaniken sind, die dir beim Ausziehen helfen. So lauter Haken und Schnüre, die mir den Hut erst mal vom Kopf nehmen. Er dreht sich so mit beiden Armen von sich gestreckt, dreht er sich durch den Raum und am Ende ist es Raum, wirst du nichts mehr an. Ja.
Weil dir alle Schuhlöffel... und Schnüre, die mir den Hut erstmal vom Kopf drehen. Und er dreht sich so mit beiden Armen von sich gestreckt, dreht er sich durch den Raum
und am Ende ist es Raum, hast du nichts mehr an.
Weil dir alle Schuhlöffel
und keine Ahnung, egal, kaputzt.
Ich glaube, ich mache es mir ein bisschen bequemer.
Alles weg.
Ui, hui.
Bisschen kalt plötzlich.
Okay, wie mache ich das? Einfach hier reinstellen?
Wo muss dieser Haken rein?
Aua, au, au, au, ach, ja, Kruzifix!
Ja, ist schwierig.
Naja.
Ja.
Nee, Hemden, also Hemden, nee, dauert zu lange, aber vielleicht manchmal auch cool.
Aber man kann die schon auch so, weil ich sehe das manchmal, vor allem bei Superman,
Clark Kent wird zu Superman, Spoiler, dass dann immer so das Hemd aufgerissen wird. Was? Ja, das musst du jetzt einfach mal hinnehmen. Ich habe kaum Beweise. Wie konsumiere ich Superman, dass ich es nicht in der ersten Folge schon weiß? Ich bin so investiert, dass ich auch nicht so sechs Folgen geguckt habe oder gelesen habe. Du bist immer nur Kompase bei den Drehs und denkst so, boah, der geile Seele. Nie gesehen, aber geil. Und dann denkst du, Moment mal, die Szenen haben was miteinander zu tun? Ich habe nämlich einen Podcast gehört, wo sie über die besten Spitznamen gesprochen haben, die es in dem Leben so gab. Und der eine hat erzählt, sie hatten mal in der Fussballmannschaft oder so, hatten sie einen Wayne Bruce. Der hieß einfach mit Vornamen Wayne und mit Nachnamen Bruce. Also haben sie ihn Man-Bet genannt. Ja, das ist perfekt. Ich glaube, das ist einfach schon der beste Spitzname. Der Nacht immer schläft und dann am Tag über seine Aufgaben... Der immer so richtig rum von der Decke hängt. Man-Bed. Man-Bed. Auch ein gar nicht so schlechter Spitzname. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee haben einige Einsendungen bekommen, vielen, vielen Dank dafür. Und natürlich ein paar. Zum Beispiel habe ich eine Einsendung bekommen von einem ehemaligen Bundeswehrsoldaten, der Schütze heißt mit Nachnamen und auch den Dienstrang Schütze innehatte und sich dann immer vorstellen musste als Schütze Schütze, was natürlich zur Heiterkeit geführt hat. Ja, fand ich sehr gut. Hier schreibt uns Alexander, liebe Pufo-Götter, gefällt mir gut, zum Thema Namen, die zum Beruf passen. Mein Name ist Moll und ich arbeite im Bereich der Audioproduktion. Sein Name ist Amoll. Abendmoll, lieben wir, fiel mir gut. Aber ist er dann auch eifersüchtig, wenn die Leute sagen, wir haben uns jetzt eher für C-Moll entschieden.
Okay, ja kein Problem, kann ich alles, ich habe es jetzt alles auf A-Moll eingestellt, aber können wir gerne machen. Dann haben wir viele spannende Bilder bekommen von irgendwelchen Praxen, Arztpraxen oder Läden, da habe ich sehr viel Spaß dran gehabt. Ninja hat uns auf Instagram eine Sparnachricht geschickt, die ich jetzt nicht vorspiele, aber es reicht völlig zu wissen, dass die Orthopädie, zu der sie immer ging, Praxisklinik, Orthopädie, Fusserkrankungen, Verletzungen von Dr. Matt Bernhard Fuss geführt und geleitet wurde. Der Orthopäde Bernhard Fuss. Der sagt, also ich am meisten interessiere mich für Füsse, für mich selbst. Ich liebe alles, was mit mir zu tun hat. Sehr schön fand ich auch von Julia eingesandt die Augenoptiker Praxis in Düsseldorf namens Ohren. Also manchmal läuft das Leben anders als erwartet. Alles war schon vorgeschrieben, aber Herr Ohren wurde Optiker. Ja. Ree, Namen und Beruf, nicht ich, aber im Krankenhaus, in welchem ich mein FSJ mache, arbeite eine Frau Goebbels, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war sie öfter für die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit zuständig. Also Frau Goebbels hat gesagt, irgendwo mache ich Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Was gibt's denn so? Und natürlich, auch für mich natürlich, ein Herzensthema. Und zwar hat mir jemand geschrieben, dass von 1998 bis 2003 war Wolfgang Wolf Fussballtrainer vom VSL Wolfsburg. Und da sage ich, herzlichen Glückwünschen. Herzlichen Glückwünschen, alles richtig gemacht, Wolfgang Wolf. Wolfgang Wolf bei VWL Wolf. Das sind Geschichten, die nur der Fussball schreibt, oder? Also das ist doch wirklich ein Traum. Ja, oder Zahnärzte, denn Sophie Therese hat uns geschrieben, Sophie hat einen tollen Zahnarzt, der heisst Doktor Schneeweiss. Oh, finde ich auch schön. Und das fand ich auch sehr gut. Arne schreibt uns hier einen Beitrag zur passenden Nachnamen. Leider kein Nachnamen mit Nazi-Vergangenheit aber trotzdem lustig. Frau Wiebke Schulleit ist die Schulleiterin der beruflichen Schulhandel. Hamburg, Hamburg. Hamburg, Hamburg. Stark. Wiebke Schulleit. Was mache ich mit meinem Leben? Was soll ich nur machen? Aber sitzen die dann bei diesem ... Wir haben damals den Tim-Test gemacht. Das Berufsinformationsratum hat den Tim-Test gemacht. Ich glaube, irgendein Herr Tim hat da mal gesagt, so, das sind die Berufe und ich habe so und so Potentialanalysen
kann ich vorbereiten und das müsst ihr,
könnt ihr alles machen. Und dann kommt
Frau Schulleit rein.
Ja.
Spricht man dann offensichtlich hier an?
Geben Sie bitte Ihre Antworten hier ein.
Bip, bup, bup, bup, bup.
Ja, Frau Schulleit.
Ja, ich glaube, wir können uns ganz gut vorstellen, dass Sie Schulleiterin werden. Wie Schulleiterin? Das macht 150 Euro bitte. 150.000 Euro. Aber diese Berufs-, also ich habe da schon so viele geile Storys gehört, was Leuten vorgeschlagen wurde, dass sie werden bei solchen Berufsorientierungen. Für mich, je konkreter es wird, desto beleidigender wird es auch. Komplett schwach sein. Also dann irgendwie sowas wie Marionettenspieler. Ja, das finde ich. Wo man wirklich, also vor allem, ich, also ich habe ja immer, wobei, ich denke ja immer, dass es irgendwie gezinkt ist im Sinne von, was die Wirtschaft gerade braucht, ja, die Wirtschaft, dass, also ich meine, natürlich, wenn du
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Minister, irgendwie Wirtschaftsminister
bist und sagst, wir brauchen wahnsinnig viele
Handwerker und Pfleger und Lehrer,
und dann gehst du zu diesen Berufsempfehlungsleuten und
sagst, Leute, wie wär's denn, empfehlt doch
bitte einfach mal jedem, einen von
diesen drei berufen zu werden. Und dann
kommen die und sagen... Ganz kurz, ich muss kurz
der Lea sagen, dass sie Marionettenspielerin werden soll.
Warum denn, wir haben alle, wir haben so viele Marionettenspieler, wir haben so viele Marionettenspieler in unserem Land, wir kriegen die kaum, es gibt nicht genug Marionetten, wir haben nicht genug Marionettenbauer, um die Marionetten zu bauen für die Marionettenspieler.
Was machen sie denn, sie machen unser Land kaputt, es kann doch nicht jeder Marionettenspieler sein.
Bleiben Sie mal ganz ruhig, gleich kommt der Tim rein, tim rein wissen was ich ihm vorschlage marionettenbauer nein also ich ja okay mag die ich möchte lea kurz noch sagen also platz eins wäre haben wir ausgerechnet mit unserem zwölfpunktplan marionettenspieler übrigens sie heißt lea marionettenspielerin marion Marionetta. Nur, wir sagen, es fließt auch rein. Ach so. Was die Marionett heisst. Lena Antoine Marionett. Okay. Und Platz drei wäre Kasperle-Theater. Ach Gott, das ist doch lächerlich. Und Platz zwei. Elfenbeinschnitzerin. Leute, wir machen hier, wir machen das alles zu. Wir machen das alles zu. Klavierbauerin. Nee, ich mach das jetzt hier zu. Ich hab keine Lust mehr. Klavierbäuerin? Nein, Bauerin. Bauerin, ja. Aber Bäuerin. Ja, gut, ist ein anderer Job. Ist ein anderer Job, ist eine sehr fingergewandte Bäuerin. Ja. Gut. Ich frag mich manchmal auch so ... Ich glaub, bei den Magnetenspielen, glaub ich, da ist die Geschichte, wo Palmer erzählt. Oh, du glaubst, es ist eine Urban Legend? Ja, Urban Legend. Urban Legend? Jetzt rein da. Das ist die Urban Legend Atomic Bomb. Hey, mach Platz da, du Trottel! Mensch, Rüder, witzig, du Vollidiot! Das ist unser nerviges Intro für unsere Urban Legends-Warnung. Für unsere Stars-Rubrik. So, schönen guten Tag, herzlich willkommen zu WDR 4 Urban Legend Warnung. Heute, Achtung, wir haben eine Urban Legend Warnung reinbekommen für Berufsinformationszentren. Der Begriff, beziehungsweise Job Marionettenspieler, wir geben eine Warnung raus, eine, seid vorsichtig, seid auch der Hutwarnung, bleibt erstmal im Haus und bleibt nicht, geht nicht ausser Häuschen. Geht nicht auf diese falsche Information ein. Seid nicht außer Häuschen. Okay, bleibt im Häuschen. Bleibt im Häuschen. Also im Sinne von lacht da nicht zu sehr drüber, weil vielleicht, ne, es handelt sich um Prank, ein Prank. Wir glauben nämlich nicht unbedingt, dass Marion Wettenspieler ein Job ist, der im Informationszentrum gesagt wird. Ich glaube, was gesagt wurde, war sowas wie Künstler. Und er hat herausgemacht, die meinten, die soll Künstler werden. Ich liebe Mathematik. Was soll ich denn mit Künstler? Die meint, die soll Marionettenspieler werden. Ah. Da hat es jemand gehört, hat gesagt. Sie erklären immer auch, wo es herkommt oder so. Die Warnung. Ganz Deutschland hört das gerade.
Ganz Deutschland hört das gerade, ohne dass sie es unterbrechen können.
Das ist eine Warnung. Jeder deutsche Bürger hat das gerade auf seinem Handy.
Ich frage aus Sicht dieses Sketches. Wer sind Sie?
Warum stehen Sie im Studio und sprüllen hier rum? Das hört ganz Deutschland.
Ich bin hier von Bayern zwei.
Ich bin hier von der Schlagerabteilung.
Was hat man Ihnen beim Berufsinformationsrendum gesagt?
Tänze.
Gehen Sie da raus und tranzen.
Wissen Sie, dann gab es diesen
einen Abend, Schwanensee.
Die Bühne war komplett
stockdunkel. Es gab nur ein Spotlight
auf die Prima Ballerina. Und es roch nach Erfolg und Neid. Es roch nach Erfolg und Schwanfedern. Doch meine Aufgabe war, ich sollte um die Prima Ballerina herumtanzen. Ich war sozusagen der See, der um sie herum brodelte, der ihre Emotionen darstellte. Mir gefällt Ballett ja nicht. Aber wie gesagt, als einzige war sie beleuchtet und der Rest der Bühne war leer. Ich musste mich also nur auf die Choreografie verlassen. Doch ich merkte schon beim Anfang des grossen Kreises, dass ich zu weit ausschärfte. Das finde ich, als ob wir das schon so oft erzählt haben. Und dann, ich tanzte, ich tanzte und ich dachte, Moment mal, ist das der Abgrund vor mir? Aber ich wusste, ich muss weiter tanzen und ich tanzte weiter und ich tanzte und plötzlich, ich fiel, ich fiel, minutenlang gefühlt und plötzlich, ah! Mein Fuss. Er war zerschmettert. Und dann kam der Anruf von Bayern 2. Bayern 3. Dann Bayern 3. Ja, und dann bin ich noch einmal aufgestiegen zu Bayern 2. Das erklärt nicht, warum sie bei WDR 4 stehen, aber so. Wir machen Schluss mit der ...
Hier ist Ronan Keating, Life is a fucking rollercoaster,
und wir tanzen jetzt da schön zusammen eine Rumba.
Okay.
Life is a rollercoaster for you.
It's going up and down like you.
Jedenfalls viele Down-Jacken bei Ando. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Gut, dass ich die Serie schon gesehen habe, damit du sie mich nicht kaputt machen kannst. Du hast nämlich manchmal die Tendenz, Leuten Sachen kaputt zu machen. Nur mit deinem Insider-Info. Okay. Okay, zum Beispiel, ich habe erfahren dass, wo wir noch mal bei Komparsen sind, dass sobald Komparsen etwas sagen, verdienen sie mehr Geld. Das heißt, es gibt manchmal in Serien viele Figuren. Genau, dann werden sie nämlich Kleindarsteller. Genau, werden sie Kleindarsteller. Und das heißt, manchmal, wenn die Produktion sehr knickerig ist, dann versuchen sie möglichst zu verhindern, dass Leute was sagen, was manchmal zu unnatürlichen Situationen führt, wenn irgendwie die Hauptfigur kommt, Entschuldigung, wo geht's denn hier zum nächsten Krankenhaus? Und der Passant nur so mit dem Kopf. Aufgeregt die Aufnahmeleiterin kommt und sagt, nicht sagen, nicht sagen, nicht sagenp, stopp, stopp, hält den Mund zu. Alles, was sie sagen, kann und wird gegen sie verwendet.
Shut up, stopp, und die antworten dann nur mit so einer Kopfbewegung und man denkt sich, hier wurde Geld gespart, katsching, hier wurde Geld gespart. Und ich gucke es mit so Dollarzeichen in den Augen und denke so, ah yes, producing, smart producing. Kann und wird.
Also eigentlich nur wird.
Es kann und wird.
Kann und oder wird.
Also alles, was ich jetzt sage, wird gegen mich verwendet.
Alles.
Wenn wir es können.
Naja, wenn ihr es tut, könnt ihr es auch.
Was man tut, kann man auch.
Das ist in der Regel.
Nichts, was man tut, kann man nicht. Doch, doch. Tanzen. Ja, aber dann tu es nicht. Ach so, ich meine schlecht tanzen. Ach so, ich verstehe. Sehr selbstreflektiert für einen Polizisten. Wollten Sie schon mal Polizist werden? Nein, das liegt mir auf dem Herzen. Nein, ich wollte immer Tänzer werden, aber dieses Der-Drecks-Professor-Doktor-Tim hat mir gesagt. Sind Sie auch Jahrgang 2013? 2013, fucking 13. Irgendwie wollen alle da Tänzer werden. Ich bin zehn Jahre alt. Warum wollen alle einen Abschluss werden, Polizisten? Warum wollen alle, die diesen Abschlussjahr hatten, Tänzer werden? Was ist da los? Abschluss, ach so. So oder so, das Krankenhaus ist da hinten und ich habe tausend Euro verdient.
Ich habe richtig viel gesagt. Jeder muss versuchen, möglichst viel zu sagen beim Set.
Das Krankenhaus ist da hinten. Scheiße, kein Smart Producing.
Nee.
Also wenn ihr Kleindarsteller seid, labert, was ihr könnt, weil nur so, nur so werdet ihr zum heiß geliebten Job Kleindarsteller aufsteigen, der gar nicht despektierlich klingt. Kleindarsteller. Genau, vielleicht schafft ihr das, könnt ihr euch langsam hocharbeiten, hin zum Lein. Wart ihr schon mal irgendwo zu sehen? Also, komm, wir machen direkt den nächsten Aufruf. Wart ihr schon mal in einem riesigen Blockbuster Kinofilm im Hintergrund zu sehen? Und jetzt stopp! Ja, ihr könntet rein theoretisch random Screenshots aus Filmen einschicken und sagen, das bin ich. Und dagegen können wir nichts machen. So wenig machen. Wir haben gegen diese Art von Betrug können wir nichts machen. Wir sind völlig schutzlos. Wir sind ein Opfertier, das auf dem Rücken liegt. Generell, ihr könnt euch das vorstellen, wir sind zwei Schildkröten, die umgekippt auf einer vielbefahrenen Strasse liegen. Wenn ihr euch fragt, wie fühlen sich vorhin und Stefan gerade, das, das. Ja, wir versuchen uns gegenseitig zu helfen, aber wir haben beide die gleiche missliche Lage. Wir wissen nicht, wo wir gelandet sind. Wir führen unser Leben so, es funktioniert. Wir rotieren stark, wir haben völlig die Orientierung verloren. Stark am Drehen. Die Autos schnell an uns vorbei. Und Vario kommt an Gefahr. Schnell an uns vorbei, so fühlen wir uns gerade. Ja. Also bitte betrügt uns nicht. Das Einzige, was wir haben, ist die hehre Bitte, uns bitte nicht
zu verscheissern, sondern
ehrlich mit uns zu sein. Schickt bitte
uns Sprachnachrichten. Warum
es kamen so viele Sprachnachrichten? Nein, hör mal auf!
Komme das von mir? Es kamen so viele Sprachnachrichten
von euch und ich habe wieder ganz vergessen,
dass ich mich so schäme beim Sprachnachrichten hören.
Hast du das auch? Ich kann nichts.
Was ich...
Also ich wollte nochmal, weil ich, ich höre ja ab und zu. Hey, gib mir das Geld, gib mir das Geld. Oh, scheiße, sorry. Ich höre ja ab und zu den Podcast meine ich jetzt, hier mit Titzler.
Und da habt ihr ja ... Hier aber das mal ...
Also da wollte ich nur so ein bisschen drauf reagieren, weil ich hab's letztens mit meiner Freundin gehört.
Da waren wir gerade im Urlaub.
Also sie ist im Urlaub, sie ist ja in Fernbeziehung.
Johnny, warte kurz, was willst du für KFC?
Oh, warte mal kurz. Was? Was willst du für KFC? Ey, kannst du mir so eine Eimer Hühnerköpfe mitnehmen, bitte? Klar, klar, klar. Oh, also, ähm, wo war ich jetzt nochmal? Also hier, ähm, hier mit dem, äh, wie heisst der nochmal, Stitzler. Hab ich euch gehört und ihr meintet ja... Alles Hände auf den Kopf. Entschuldigung, ich hab hier gerade, Entschuldigung, sorry, ich muss kurz unterbrechen. Aber so ist es auch, Spannachrichten, es ist immer so viel im Hintergrund los, dass man sich denkt, was würdet ihr für Leben? Wo seid ihr gerade? Oder der unfokussierteste Gesprächsfluss, den man überhaupt nur haben kann. Aber was für eine merkwürdige Art des Sprechens, weil alle haben gesagt, als das Chatten aufkam, krass, was wir das uns Menschen werden, gut, wir können weiter ausholen, damals, als die Dampflog erfunden wurde, haben alle gesagt, wir werden wahnsinnig, wenn wir auf dieser Geschwindigkeit, wenn Menschen so schnell reisen, werden wir wahnsinnig. Ja, wenn Knöpfe so schnell verschwinden, irgendwann, wie soll die Kleidung an uns halten, wie hält sie an unseren Körpern? Beim Chat großer Paradigmenwechsel, man spricht plötzlich anders, man kann Sachen wieder löschen.
Man, normalerweise, wenn man spricht, es ist eine sehr unmittelbare, anders als Briefe, sehr unmittelbare Korrespondenz, trotzdem kann man Sachen wieder löschen und so.
Alles anders, alles neu. Und jetzt kommen diese Sprachen nachher, ich glaube, die sind noch weirder, die sind so komisch, das ist eine komische Art, dieses Monologhalten, das ist ja so merkwürdig, es ist fast wieder wie Mails eher, wo man dann auch viel schreibt. Ohne Korrektur einfach. Monolog, ohne Korrektur, wie man es gerade so spricht, es ist so unnötig. Aber das ist doch der nächste Schritt KI, oder? Du sprichst acht Minuten Sprachmitteilung und dann sagst du, möchten Sie, dass diese Sprachnachricht zusammengefasst wird? Ja, und sie ist plötzlich 40 Sekunden lang. Und geschrieben. Geschrieben, kann man ja eh schon sich umsetzen lassen. Aber das ist echt ein ewiger Kampf. Ich habe auch tatsächlich mittlerweile einen titanischen Kampf, ein ewiges Ringen mit Steuerpersonen begonnen, die Mails nutzt gerne und ich gerne telefoniert und ich nutze gerne Mails. und immer wenn wir telefonieren, sagt einer von uns, wir können beim nächsten Mal auch einfach eine Mail schreiben. Und immer wenn, ja, sag ich, und immer wenn eine Mail geschrieben wird, sagt, Sie können mich auch einfach anrufen unter. Und ich sag immer, Sie können mir übrigens auch eine Mail schreiben unter, Flur und in der End. Und es ist wirklich immer, egal was, es ist ein ewiger Kreislauf und niemand gibt nach. Was machst du falsch? Niemand gibt nach. Sie können sich melden unter der Nummer, aber Sie können sich melden auf der E-Mail-Adresse, wo wohnt hin will. Moment, wirklich? Weiß ich nicht. Melden Sie sich unter, Sie können mir übrigens auch so dieses, also das, was man eigentlich schon seit Jahren versucht durchzudrücken, so als, oh, falls Sie es noch gar nicht wussten, es gibt E-Mails.
Übrigens, ich wollte nur sagen, Sie können mir auch eine E-Mail schreiben, obwohl der das explizit vehement seit Jahren nicht tut, wird es so, oh übrigens, ganz kurz, Sie können mir auch einfach eine E-Mail schreiben.
Aber es ist ein bisschen verklausuliert, ganz kurz, Sie können mir auch einfach unpersönlicher das Ganze mitteilen.
Ach so.
Ja, genau, einfach, dass wir weniger miteinander zu tun haben, menschlich. Ach so, ach so, nee, nee, nee, ich verstehe, aber nur damit Sie es wissen, wir können das Ganze auch persönlicher und direkter machen und schneller. Nee, ich würde es gerne viel komplizierter, dass man Dinge übersieht, viel unpersönlicher und distanzierter machen, okay, dankeschön. Du, übrigens, wir können es auch so machen, wie ich will. Wir können es auch machen, wie ich, der Kunde, das will. Sie kriegen ja Geld von mir. Nur als kleine Randinformation, es gibt eine Möglichkeit, wie wir es so machen können, dass es alle meine Forderungen erfüllt. Herr Tietze? Mit freundlichen Grüßen, Flogen den Willen. Herr Tietze? Ich freue mich nicht auf Ihre Antwort, mit freundlichen Grüßen. Ich schreibe immer liebe Grüße aus Köln, weil ich finde, dass, ich weiss gar nicht, warum. Aus dem sonnigen Köln, die Sünners. Aus dem sonnigen. Von Agatha Bernhard und dem kleinen Bibo. Bibo? Was ist das für ein Geschäft? Das ist eine Biene. Unsere Haustierbiene Bibo. Bzzzzz. Und dann noch PS, Bibo. Bzzzzz. Und das einfach bei so einer Mahnung vom Finanzamt. Ja, überweisen wir gleich. Liebe Grüße aus dem sonnigen Köln. Und Bibo sagt Bzzzzz. Wenn eine Mahnung ins Haus flattert, ist mein erster Gedanke immer ungelogen, was haben die jetzt wieder falsch gemacht. Wirklich? Ja, es ist nie. Wow, 180 Grad von mir, das ist, oh scheiße, ich habe was falsch gemacht. Bei mir ist immer, ich habe zu 100% Recht, der, dessen Job es ist, das zu kontrollieren und den Cashflow zu überprüfen und entdeckt, dass ich nicht bezahlt habe, ist zu 100 Prozent falsch. Ich habe so einen Rechnungs-Narzissmus. Ich habe wieder eine saftige Mahnung bekommen. Richtig dick, so richtig dick ist rot. Geht's dir gut? Also der Brief selber war in schwarz-weiß, aber das Wort Mahnung war in rot und schief. Also wirklich reinste Thumbnail-Kunst. Rot und schief, Mahnung über drei Euro. Ihr habt mich gesagt, so, jetzt, Kollege, jetzt die Farbe alleine kostet 16 Euro. Dieses Amarone-Rot, Nummer 24, die wir da benutzt haben, sehe ich hier im Internet, kostet 4,50 Euro. Die Mahnung, die Sie mir schicken, für drei Euro, hat sich nicht gelungen. Und ich war kurz davor, zurückzuschreiben, uuuh, was passiert dann, wenn ich das jetzt nicht zahle? So ein Video, von dem du so ein Fünfer ansteckst. Muss ich dann 50 Sekunden ins Gefängnis? Uuuh, oh nein, Hilfe, bitte nicht! Aber es ist ja gar nicht so weit hergeholt, weil, vor ein paar Monaten war das eine ganz krasse Diskussion in Berlin, weil da die Gefängnisse... Da war ich leider nicht dabei. Die Gefängnisse waren überflutet, weil Verkehrssünder, selbst für 10 Euro, oder du wirst beim Schwarzfahren erwischt, 40 Euro, und du kannst es nicht zahlen, weil vielleicht sind das Obdachlose oder so gewesen oder Leute, die auf der Straße leben, was auch immer, kein Geld haben, die 40 Euro nicht haben, die werden dann vorgeladen, vor das Gericht haben nicht gezahlt und die kriegen dann eine Freiheitsstrafe. Nur über ein paar Tage, aber die kriegen, müssen dann bestraft werden für ihr Vergehen. Also werden die in Gefängnisse gesteckt und dann waren die Gefängnisse in Berlin voll. Und weil härtere Strafenden da irgendwie ja beschlossen wurden. Und dann einfache Lösung, warum ist eine Freiheitsstrafe auf Falschfahren ausgesetzt? Was war nur Falschfahrer? So, vielleicht ist da was falsch, weil Bußgelder zum Beispiel, nee, Bußgelder müssen, glaube ich, so behandelt werden, aber es gibt noch eine andere Form von Strafe, wo dann nicht die Freiheitsstrafe da draufsteht. Aber bei diesem Delikt, das muss dann am Ende, steht dann die Freiheitsstrafe. Und dann wurden so Richter mal interviewt, warum man das nicht einfach lösen kann. Und dann meinte er, nee, Freiheitsstrafen ist total wichtig, weil das ist der Backbone dieses ganzen Systems. Strafen werden ja komplett hinfällig. Die höchste Straf, ja. Wenn du nicht da hinten kannst, das ist wie der Vater, der sagt, jetzt sage ich bis drei. Genau. Und wenn der Staat dann nichts tun würde bei drei, dann bricht alles zusammen. Wir wüssten es nämlich. Wir würden nämlich merken, wenn ein Obdachloser fährt schwarz, hat das Geld nicht, sagt er das Geld nicht und kommt dann nicht in den Knast, ihm passiert nichts, würden wir merken, Papa hat nichts, wenn er bis drei zählt. Er hat nichts. Er hat gar nichts. Er macht nichts. Wir fahren alle schwarz. Und der Richter meinte so, so ein hoher Bundesrichter sogar, nee, es geht nicht, es muss irgendwie was geben. und ich fand das spannend, weil es gibt keine Lösung dafür, es ist natürlich völlig albern, dass Leute, die sich das nicht leisten können, für so wenig Vergehen im Knast landen, auf der anderen Seite, natürlich wäre es chaoslos, wenn es anders wäre. Aber wie funktioniert das, was darf man mitnehmen ins Gefängnis, also kommst du da mit einem Wechselsatz Kleidung oder kriegst du da diesen orangen Anzug oder also? Ich glaube, man kriegt Kleidung. Man kriegt Kleidung und Wäsche und Zahnbürste. Moment, also du hast gar nichts selber, was dir gehört im Gefängnis. Du kannst ein paar Sachen mitnehmen. Du hast einen Rucksack mit. Darf ich meinen Laptop mitnehmen? Ins Gefängnis? Oder sagen die... Nein, den kriegst du irgendwann dann vielleicht, wenn du bei guter Führung... Also bei guter Führung werde ich nach drei Tagen entlassen. Und dann kriege ich am zweiten Tag mein Laptop. Die ersten drei Tage, drei Stunden. So, wir schauen uns jetzt die nächsten 20 Minuten an, Herr Will. Wenn Sie da keinen Aufstand planen, dann kriegen Sie Ihren Laptop. Und wenn Sie sich die Nacht gut benehmen, dann können Sie morgen noch einen offenen Vollzug. Aber das fand ich spannend, weil was will man machen? Naja, was ich jetzt immer sehe, und das ist meine Lieblingsgruppe mittlerweile, muss ich sagen, weil es gibt so eine Gruppe, die machen Sozialstunden, glaube ich zumindest, weil das ist eine absolut bunt zusammengewürfelte Gruppe Menschen und die alle den gleichen neongrünen Anzug anhaben und alle zusammen wie bei so einem Klassentreffen so in so einer, niemand will da wirklich sein, aber man muss es halt machen und die gehen durch Köln und sammeln Müll ein, haben aber auch
Spaß dabei, weil das sind irgendwie auch
Leute, die so zusammengewürfelt sind, das ist eine
absolut bunte Truppe und ich denke immer so, das sind
so ganz verschiedene Kriminelle, so Steuerhinterzug
und irgendwie Diebstermord,
Körperverletzung und so
und die finde ich geil, weil die würde ich
gerne den ganzen Tag begleiten,
wie die so unterschiedlich sind und dann durch die Gegend laufen und die finde ich auch mal spannend. Toll, ja, ja, voll. Dann gab es nämlich so eine Website, wo man Geld spenden konnte, um die freizukaufen. Weil für solche Leute, die eine geringe Strafe haben und ein paar Tage Freiheitsstrafe haben, ist dann die Kaution auch nicht so hoch. Das heißt, man haben online dann sehr viele Anonyme Obdachlose oder
sehr Geringverdiener aus dem
Knast rausgekauft.
Fand ich eine gute Idee.
Könnt ihr mal gucken am Internet, wenn ihr da
ein paar Euro über habt, könnt ihr Leute aus dem
Knast rauskaufen, die sich einfach nicht leisten können,
die Buße zu zahlen.
Ja, es ist wirklich
crazy, aber es gibt keine einfache Lösung.
Das ist so ein Problem, wo clevere Leute mal nachdenken müssen, nicht immer nur wir. Ja, warum hängt das alles immer an uns? Man bleibt das alles immer an uns hängen. Ja, ich verstehe es wirklich nicht. Und spürst du auch diesen Atlas-Riesen, wie Atlas haben wir das ganze Kosmos auf den Schultern? die auf unseren Schildern ruht. Fast Sisyphos-artig müssen wir jede Woche erneut diesen großen Stein da hochrollen. Sisyphos-artig ist es wie bei Atlas und dem großen Kosmos auf dem Rücken. Damokles-artig steht uns nämlich das Schwert quasi ins Gesicht. Ja, genau. Ja. Mehr haben wir nicht. Das sind genau ihr Icarus-Haft. Gehen wir in die Luft. Sind wir so kurz davor, in die Luft zu gehen? Das ist auch dumm Griechen, oder? Die dachten, wenn man in die Luft fliegt, wird es wärmer. Heute können wir dieser Metapher nichts mehr abgewinnen. Nee, wir können ins Gesicht lachen. Weil wir sagen, nee, es wird kälter, wenn man nach oben fliegt. Der kann noch besser fliegen, wenn er ganz nah an die Sonne fliegt. Weil er nicht mal gegen Luftwiderstand kämpft. Ja, weißt du, also da hat die Physik hier irgendwie Agamemnon einfach auch ein Schnippchen geschlagen. Hat Agamemnon geblieben. Kannst du den Agamemnon noch ins Ad setzen einfach? Ad Agamemnon. CC. Hast du Agamemnon in CC? Kannst du Cicero nicht in CC setzen, bitte? Du, kannst du Cicero und Cäsar noch in CC setzen, bitte? Re-CC-Fliege. Aber schwierig, also schwer das zu übersetzen. Man bräuchte irgendwas, was kaputt geht, wenn es kalt wird. Aber was gibt es da? Aber es wird erst viel kälter und dann viel zu heiß. Ja gut, das stimmt natürlich. Wir wissen nicht, wie weit Icarus geflogen ist. Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das wird erst mal eine ganze Weile kälter, oder? Ja, ich glaube, das wäre eher sein Problem gewesen, als zu nah an die Sonne zu fliegen. Aber haben sich die damals wirklich vorgestellt, dass es heiß wird, wenn man nach oben geht, oder was?
Ja, aber ich will uns mal sehen in der Zeit, wie wir Trottel nicht mal in der Lage sind, diesen Gedanken zu formulieren.
Stefan, bist du dir sicher, dass du diesen Ast essen willst?
Nein, nein, nein.
Wo geht's denn jetzt zum KFC?
Entschuldigung, Buenos Dias! Ja, ist nicht KFC. Wo ist denn der KFC? Auch so ein Säulengebäude. Die CFC, oder? Haben Lateiner nicht, die haben doch kein K. Ja, CFC. CFC. Centurio Fried Chicken. CC, CFC und dann Centurium Friedum Chickenum. Guck mal, da haben wir doch schon mal wieder, da haben wir doch eine Sketch-Serie, oder? Einfach schön alles nochmal zurückgespult. Ja, für Funk reicht's. Ich wünsche euch eine fantastische Woche. Ich wünsche dir, Florenton, eine fantastische Woche. Ich werde eine schöne Woche haben. Ja, und das werde ich mir auch fest vorgenommen. Und davon werde ich auch mir nicht abbringen lassen. Aber wenn ihr keine schöne Woche habt, ist das auch völlig okay. Man kann auch nicht immer eine schöne Woche haben, auch wenn wir es immer wünschen.
Und macht das Beste draus.
Wir haben den Januar fast geschafft.
Ich haut rein.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis dahin, macht's gut.
Viel Spaß, haut rein. Wir heben ab!
It's a Worst Bird production.